all right will your retirement feel the
crunch
when you try to buy lunch it's true
unless you're rolling like a pimp you
can't afford the shrimp
it's true lunch flashing is sweeping the
nation as workers returning to the
office face insane price hikes on
popular lunch items thanks to a surge in
menu prices not seen in 40 years you're
gonna have to take a second job to save
up for that tuna sandwich since last
march the average price of wraps is up
18
sandwiches 14 salads 11 but who cares
right
burgers eight percent meanwhile popular
chains like sweet green and pot belly
have raised prices roughly six percent
since the start of the year and to save
money mcdonald's replaced special sauce
with special report sauce
it's made from bread bears aftershave
i can relate to this absurd price hike
my soup from hail and hardy was 17
yesterday
i'm not joking which makes it far too
expensive to dump on my assistant if
it's cold
it's true meanwhile other companies are
capitalizing on the price hikes in
really unusual ways
[Music]
hey fat ass are you tired of lunches
that leave you stuffed and bloated not
really
did you just call me fat ass well bloat
no more with lunchables the pre-made
lunches for today's smaller appetites
i think someone's already been eating
this
and why are there matches
let's not worry about that now at just
dollars per meal lunchables are one heck
of a deal
he's right you know
you can hear him too oh yes he's the one
who gave me the courage to finally
murder my wife's boyfriend
lunchables they're for everyone
cash uh your name is cash so technically
you due to inflation will be worth less
what yes
and you just ruined my mother's evening
[Laughter]
is she watching probably ah yeah she's
like your number one supporter oh good
for her she's probably wishes i were her
son probably
you're like the you're like the white me
with more money oh that's probably true
well i figured you would being in the
tech industry would have been very rich
my tech business is booming
the funny thing is it's about to be
we'll come back to that i knew it
yes i could see it in the future do you
have thoughts on this topic well cue the
music it's peanut butter jelly time it's
peanut butter jelly time no okay you
guys totally missed it i'm oh you get it
julie gets it i'll sing it it took me i
think you're probably asking the wrong
guy because i grew up eating peanut
butter and jelly for 10 years and then
my parents made enough money for me to
get lunchables
so i stayed out of the inflation market
because we were just priced out of it i
can't believe you've paid 17 for
freaking soups it's amazing it's it's
does fox pay for that or no i paid i
give i give my assistant 20 bucks and uh
you let her keep the change
you know what i you know i am lenny's
not letting her keep this yeah where's
my three bucks it's gonna be at all can
you give me a food card yes i can
it'll be you can it'll be a punch card
yes so every time you're gonna have to
kiss me and then the tenth kiss i get
the punch in the face don't give me
incentives i don't even know what i'm
saying at this point and i haven't even
been drinking yet cat
um
do you even eat lunch have pierogies
gone up in price
have you rushed
so it was like body shaming and then
kind of racist
i tried to put him together he said it
up he was racist here
uh i actually also usually don't eat
lunch
are you eating more beans i have
nicotine gum and vivants but like well
the vitamins i have in the morning
because i have adhd so that was also
kind of ableist
um
but i guess this proves that when over
the summer joe biden said inflation was
temporary he was kind to right because
that inflation was temporary now we have
way bigger inflation
and it's going to keep getting worse it
is going to get worse you know uh julie
uh they were also telling us telling us
i guess it was a couple of days ago that
we should eat more beans
more beans i don't know if that's a good
idea for you that was a married person
who said that for sure i actually i
think people do not eat beans absolutely
married eat beans that's actually that's
a great idea i've already given up
canned beans i gave up many years ago
long before now so but yeah i'd say
canned beans is is the way to go i
support that you have any statistics
you'd like to share that i've already
mentioned
is there a particular can of beans well
yeah goya um i think is good you know go
go spanish do you know uh
interesting fact you can't you can't
spell legume without
you and me you said that yesterday i did
it's true okay why don't you burn it
into my brain you can't spell legume
without you
where did you learn that stupid it came
to me last night like in school i've not
said anything of substance in this topic
well okay so i would say as far as going
out to eat then make your lunch at home
and take it to the office and we don't
all have assistants that fetch us raps
that's another that's another segment
right there is that substantive enough
for you
i'll take it you know but i'll rely on
trace all right um trace this is one of
those situations where forget solutions
just deal with it that's what we always
get from from the damn liberals
the damn liberals they're just like hey
inflation we can't solve inflation we'll
just you're just gonna have to suffer
but we won't suffer because we're rich
liberals you like that let me tell you
something that's my red meat the whole
the whole concept of this is people are
now just coming back to the office i
mean i was in manhattan a few months ago
and nobody was at this place i go to in
the corner today there was a line out
the door people are just now coming back
the suit you need to buy after being in
sweats for two years is 50 more it's
also more to dry clean it you got to get
gas to get in here the lunch is 15 bucks
where it used to be nine that cup of
coffee in the morning is five bucks and
if you are on the edge if you're a
democrat moderate democrat independent
you don't like it and you're going this
way that's why the bite administration
is freaking out now blaming putin
blaming everybody because now people are
back in the mix and they're like
what happened i don't care you know
putin might be laughing biden's sitting
in the chair it's happening on his watch
and if you're right in the middle you're
going this way you're bumping this way
when you go by six buck gas yeah how
long before you're going to see people
the street you know fighting over an
organic crunchy salad from predamon j
everyone in there always looks so sad is
that how you pronounce it predamon j
well that's how i pronounce it i mean
you could spread a manger
i think that would be weird trace but it
might be a good opportunity for
inflation could lead to deflation i.e
eating less lose weight
starve
that's what i say
because i don't give a damn all right up
next spring break criminal activity or
supreme court inclusivity hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else